well and that's actually an interesting
part of the show right kind of post
jackpot
um it's massive massive government
control right I mean they're controlling
I mean literally what people think but
it happens in society and I mean to your
point on the prepper side and this is
something I've been working on in the
state treasurer's office I'm sure you've
seen these MCC codes they're putting in
place for credit cards now to be able to
track the purchase of guns and
ammunition around the country this is a
back door uh National gun registry and
this was pushed by Elizabeth Warren and
the Raz so if you are buying guns right
now pay cash or uh check but this is
something that we're going to have
legislation on in January in West
Virginia hopefully other states are
replicated and it's actually not the
credit card companies that want to track
this it's the banks the banks want to
track it and then the banks are going to
be able to say oh we're going to flag
this so you're going to flag this